you're welcome to this video I'm playing
van m / from our fun ever um here German
I am he always plays g6 this is fire I
went to be three but at the anterior he
got in his g6 move so we have an English
opening this is a very very strategical
setup but a good one very playable for
white okay he provokes me to play you
fall it's not a big deal getting into
this what the Vinick type of position um
okay but let's transpose into a king's
indian after he takes we have 400 o
Kings Indian all of a sudden okay I need
to cover your form
yeah 95 and so on but still so I think
what should be good here I always
believe in the center I admit I admit to
that okay um scammer this
okay yes got some pressure against your
phone other than that white is in
excellent shape question is how to
proceed as g45 good or is this is too
crude gaining even more space that could
be could be too crude very very much
possible okay I play a prophylactic move
so that after a five before
he probably wants to play Queen before
and a phone
okay is there some some way to make
progress in the center it's not
self-evident okay let's follow this
planet may be risky or something but
don't want to play a slow moves okay and
yeah he's got definite counter play on
the queenside
yeah I don't didn't see anything else
it's not good of course
yeah okay the skips rb5 I know but I
need to get some hope here and this is
may be connected with f6 at least I'm
getting his Bishop to have eight and
hoping for some summer tag here okay
yeah I didn't 93 obviously but it
material is already not so important I
need to get some direct attack going
everything else feels anyway okay giving
up before four this age 5 News
so let's say a play Queen edge form
intending to take on g6
and also night d 5 is in the mix now
yeah you can always play Queen f2 and
get the Queen's off but at least I'm
getting a piece back
yeah the real bad thing is he didn't
only outplay me also did this very
quickly in terms of time management I'm
down on the clock yeah they are probably
most Edwin
chan love to mm-hmm taking me five
hmm
there's no trick here no trick at all
check unfortunately
yeah but I can take is this way that can
take if to at the end it's
check
yeah yeah yeah yeah did I could could
also safely resign this was the some
trick some trick left here probably not
yeah as long as the king is somewhat
boxed in I can um I can I can try time
morning threatening man threatening
nothing nothing is not much I know check
yeah he's worthless bloody check check
check
check-check
okay I'm not sure maybe it's almost
almost a game again probably not check
check
check
check check white [ __ ] face oh yeah I
could have resigned earlier I know yeah
it was simply not working all this this
a 4 counterplay was Sir was too strong I
mean I don't really have an attack here
and and I probably need around here and
I need to improve or even a form a
problem it's possible maybe this is the
center's more weakness
yeah he's going to play for and then my
queen side collapses I probably should
should avoid should avoid even even a
form and play a more normal more normal
can I move Knight be five or something
this is a pretty normal move oops this
is quite okay if he goes 95 that's 95
something like that I probably need to
do that for some is too much this is
weakening too much he's got this this
pawn to attack and this a 4 idea and
then in the game it was after a form I'm
falling apart so it's really no way to
oops really no way to get a playable
position again and okay this is
completely dead check check they're
always always piece down or something
right thanks for watching